bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
sport numéro 39 allez c'est parti pour
un nouveau tour de l'actu sport en 26
minutes du département il est le nouveau
champion de France de boxe
professionnelle catégorie Walter le
verriez roi Ahmed El moussaouya conquis
la ceinture tricolore ce week-end après
une victoire au point portrait à suivre
après cinq saisons passées sur le banc
de Montigny Stéphane paysan a été limogé
de son poste d'entraîneur il nous a
accordé sa première interview et donne
sa vérité dans ce 7 8 sport nous allons
partir dans les traces des courses de
chiens de traîneau portrait de deux
pilotes les motion qui vaut une passion
inédite à leurs équipages et puis
évidemment en fin d'émission comme
d'habitude tous les résultats du
week-end mes places tout d'abord à notre
page spéciale box
ce combat pour la ceinture de champion
de France pouvait faire basculer sa
carrière le jeune verrier Roy Amed el
Moussaoui a donc décroché la ceinture de
champion Walter de boxe face à Franck à
rocheforta ce week-end à 23 ans le
prince de la boxe voulait prouver qu'il
était devenu un autre boxeur capable de
se hisser au sommet nous avons suivi sa
préparation avec Jonathan Wilman
il y a encore huit mois Ahmed El
Moussaoui ne tenait pas cet exercice
plus de deux minutes à deux jours du
combat pour la ceinture de champion de
France Walter il va enchaîner les
frappes pendant plus d'un quart d'heure
c'est à La Verrière à l'âge de 8 ans
qu'amède el Moussaoui découvre la boxe
sur les conseils d'un habitant du
quartier ce qui n'est qu'un simple
amusement au départ va vite devenir une
passion en 2002 il change de club et
pris sous l'aile de la famille Farrugia
Élancourt il domine alors l'hexagone
avec quatre titres de champion de France
en cadet et en junior mais pour
continuer sa progression le prince avait
besoin de se mettre en danger il quitte
alors l'équipe de France en 2009 et
passe chez les professionnels en février
dernier il part aux États-Unis pour
quelques semaines malgré la dureté des
entraînements livinois décide de rester
trois mois sous les ordres de Joseph à
winongia ex entraîneur de champion du
monde là-bas on a plus de comment dire
les entraîneurs sont beaucoup plus
dédiés on s'est la première fois que que
je m'entraîne au studio ma vie
surtout que quand mon entraîneur il
vient me chercher à n'importe quelle
heure on va s'entraîner pendant 4-5
heures sans s'arrêter c'est pas évident
très particulier très spécial très
rapide il s'est réagir très vite sur un
ring je ne sais pas combien de boxeurs
j'ai entraîné depuis le début de ma
carrière eux ils faisaient du bon boulot
mais avec Ahmed je veux lui apporter
quelque chose et lui montrer qu'il peut
devenir un grand boxeur après un second
séjour à Chicago le frenchy est revenu
transformer des États-Unis vous me
reposez la question et à 5-6 mois je
voudrais répondu que je suis un
technicien mais là je suis un boxeur
complément donc je sais tout faire
depuis son passage chez les
professionnels Amédée Moussaoui enchaîne
les victoires 17 au total pour une
défaite et un match nul pour son retour
en France Le Verrier Roy va mettre les
gants pour une ceinture pour la première
fois et ce serait très attendu je suis
sûr de mes capacités après vous savez la
box en un coup tout peut changer donc
voilà et surtout je sous-estime pas mon
adversaire
samedi soir à Cergy-Pontoise le prince
de la verrière pourrait franchir la plus
haute marge de sa jeune carrière une
marche qui pourrait le hisser vers les
sommets de la box mondiale
et nous devrions avoir la première
réaction de d'Amed el Moussaoui après
son titre d'ici la fin de ce 7 8 sport
après cinq saisons passées sur le banc
de Montigny je le disais dans les titres
Stéphane paysan a été limogé de son
poste d'entraîneur suite à des ennuis de
santé pour tout vous dire il nous a
accordé ça toute première interview et
donne sa vérité sur son départ plutôt
surprenant du club
première question comment vous allez
très bien très bien très bien mais un
souci de santé sont passés depuis
maintenant plus d'un mois et voilà je
suis plus entré dans mon tuning mais la
santé ça va que s'est-il passé on va
dire peut-être au niveau personnel pour
que vous laissiez un peu le terrain de
côté bah en fait au match de plus grands
championnat j'ai eu un problème de voix
j'étais donc à faune j'avais plus de
voix du tout déjà pour le managera donc
c'était un peu compliqué et en fait la
semaine d'après j'étais en médecin qui
m'a dit de stopper si je continuais
c'était un peu problématique ça ne se
soignerait pas donc j'ai arrêté pendant
trois semaines en fait autant que ça se
remette et puis voilà après j'étais
disponible mais malheureusement il y a
plus de poste pour moi donc je me suis
fait entraîner de Montigny comment ça il
y avait plus de poste je sais qu'il y
avait un intérim la personne de Monsieur
lerange qui qui a pris l'intérim sur le
banc de la N2 et vous n'aviez plus votre
place derrière non non il y avait plus à
place parce que en fait moi je suis
disponible à partir du vendredi soir et
le samedi matin signifie que non la
présence de Philippe le tranchant sera
définitive à partir du vendredi en fait
c'était définitif et que donc voilà
j'avais plus de poste pour moi donc moi
je t'ai disponible pour le club de
Montigny sauf que eux n'avait plus de
poste pour moi donner donc bah voilà je
me suis retrouvé sans club
c'est voilà ça c'est fini un petit peu
en queue de poisson si j'ose dire non il
y a eu un petit conflit sur cette
période là ça a été compliqué parce que
je sais pas aller on dit il y a eu plein
de choses qui ont été dites et qui ont
pas été vrai je pense et voilà moi j'ai
pas pu m'expliquer avec mes joueuses
parce qu'après cette donnée compliqué de
venir au gymnase en fait on est arrivé à
ce point-là donc donc voilà donc non
c'est ça fait mal parce que bon ça fait
quand même c'était ma sixième année
j'attaqué ma sixième année et après 5
ans passés au club et on fait ce que
j'ai fait au club je pense que ouais
c'est un peu compliqué maintenant c'est
bon j'ai pris le dessus mais franchement
les premières semaines ont été
compliquées on nous reverra donc plus
sur le banc de Montigny ou sur un banc
chez les jeunes c'est définitif c'est
définitif moi je suis encore disponible
de toute façon pour l'instant je n'ai
pas de club je suis disponible le club
le sait de me voir Montigny ça peut être
un peu compliqué en tout cas pour
l'instant je même moi de moi-même je ne
vais pas dans le dans club et je vais
pas dans les tribunes j'ai été voir
l'équipe 2 de Montigny à l'extérieur
parce que c'est un peu compliqué avec
certains dirigeants c'est un peu
conflictuel pour l'instant on va parler
de votre bilan vous avez passé cinq
saisons plein vous attaquez vous le
disiez votre sixième saison comment vous
voyez justement ce bilan là ces cinq
saisons passées à Montigny je pense que
regarder bilan ou c'est quand même du
positif parce que moi j'ai récupéré
l'équipe a le temps N3
elle descendait de N1 puis de N2 puis en
3 il y avait pas mal de problématiques
moi je récupère l'équipe la première
année était très très compliqué très
très compliqué parce qu'on aura dû
descendre alors lui descend par contre
les quatre saisons d'après on est quand
même monté en N2 ou bien terminer sur
deux saisons de N2 on établi 5e sur des
grosses grosses saisons le pôle féminin
qui n'existait pas du tout il y a 5 ans
maintenant un peu plus haut niveau dans
toutes les catégories jeunes donc voilà
donc je pense que le bilan est plutôt
positif
voilà après et puis la dernière saison
est assez symbolique j'ai envie de dire
parce que au début de saison la saison
dernière vous ramenez un petit peu comme
on dit dans le jargon et puis petit à
petit le groupe se retrouve et puis vous
avez réussi à grappiller les places
jusqu'à cette 5e place en journée plus
finir 4e si on avait un peu mieux
négocié sur la fin de saison à partir du
moment le maintien était vraiment assuré
que la cinquième place est assurée on
s'est un peu relâché mais ce qui est
normal parce que les filles ont vraiment
fait un début de saison comme tu dis
très chaotique puis de janvier à avril
on a fait vraiment un très très bon
parcours
voilà on a terminé 5e franchement la
poule de l'année dernière était très
très difficile il y avait quand même des
réserves fleuries ici Rennes au noix en
fait vraiment des gros grosses équipes
donc voilà donc on a fait vraiment deux
belles saisons et c'était vraiment très
très content tu es parti pour une
sixième saison et je pense en plus
surtout que cette saison là la poule est
beaucoup plus faible entre guillemets
parce qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'équipes c'était plus homogène
3 il y a plus les grosses équipes plus
les Aubrais la réserve de Fleury est
partie dans la poule 1 donc il y avait
vraiment moyen de faire des quelque
chose de bien cette année mais j'espère
que les filles vont relever la tête pour
l'instant elles sont mal parti mais
elles ont fait beaucoup de matchs à
l'extérieur donc je pense que vous
enlever la tête ça va un petit peu mieux
là c'est ces dernières semaines cinq
saisons passées à Montigny j'imagine
qu'il y a des joueuses ou peut-être une
joueuse qui vous a marqué
particulièrement
il y a plusieurs joueuses je m'entendais
vraiment bien avec certaines joueuses
avec d'autres forcément c'est plus
problématique partir vraiment les
joueuses jouent plus ça se passe mieux
celle que je joue moins forcément plus
après l'entraîneur mais non j'avais très
bon rapport avec avec Gaby la capitale
avec Fanny Jean-Baptiste aussi avec qui
je suis en rapport par rapport au match
et voilà donc ces deux joueuses là
effectivement pour le marquer ouais il y
a eu des périodes difficiles sur ces 5
saisons quand même même si c'est de
retenir toujours un peu le côté tout le
début de saison toujours été compliqué
cette année c'est pareil même si c'est
plus mon entraîneur on a toujours eu du
mal à se mettre en route alors c'est
vraiment vous expliquer ça je pense que
c'est un problème d'entraîneur je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose qu'on rate en
début de saison à chaque fois alors
est-ce que c'est la préparation mine de
rien de la mi-août jusqu'à début de
championnat ce que c'est ça qui qui fait
que ça ne marche pas mais depuis
toujours on a toujours jusqu'en décembre
toujours des problèmes énormes et après
par contre une fois que la dynamique est
bien parti ça ça part sur le bonne base
mais le début de saison a toujours été
très très problématique démarrage diesel
un petit peu et on souvent fait des
réunions à chaque fois de crise entre
guillemets et parce que ben voilà il
faut régler les problèmes et dès qu'on a
fait sur union là en général ça allait
mieux on voit vous revoir bientôt sur un
banc ivinois ou ailleurs peut-être non
pour l'instant pas de piste le problème
du handball c'est qu'on ne vire pas les
entraîneurs même en cours de saison
c'est extrêmement rare donc pour
l'instant je vais voir des matchs de NF
fille pour voir un peu le niveau et puis
me jauger un peu au niveau majara par
rapport aux entraîneurs en place donc
voilà j'aimerais bien un projet
effectivement de région qui a envie de
monter en National ou national qui a
envie d'aller plus loin mais un projet
ambitieux j'ai pas envie d'un projet là
j'avais des propositions en
départementales ça m'intéresse pas c'est
c'est pas de la prétention c'est
simplement que c'est trop long à mettre
en place à changer le comportement des
joueurs ou des joueuses donc non non je
préfère attendre je vais attendre et
puis si c'est un mois sans club c'est
pas grave ça dépend mon métier donc
c'est la chance que j'ai
la rédaction du 7 8 sport s'agrandit
depuis aujourd'hui puisque l'athlète
yvinoise nantonnin kaïta va désormais
vous faire découvrir son coup de coeur
sportif une fois par mois bonsoir
Antonin bonsoir Anthony je vais vous
présenter un petit peu pour nos
téléspectateurs en deux mots vous êtes
championne du monde du 200 mètres et du
400 mètres en 2006 à Hassen des au
niveau des malvoyants et double
médaillés de bronze au jeu de
paralympiques de 2008 et de 2012 donc
pour votre première chronique chronique
pardon vous allez nous présenter un
athlète 50 chinois tout à fait Anthony
alors pour cette première chronique j'ai
décidé de vous présenter babacar Diop
qui est un athlète en devenir vous allez
vite comprendre mon choix je vous laisse
regarder
je m'appelle Babacar j'ai 17 ans
je suis en terminale des au lycée des 7
morts et on atteint du 200 et du 400
mètres je suis arrivé en cadet à la base
c'était plutôt parti pour faire du 100
mètres et du 200 mais au vu de mes
qualités avec
la mon gabarit
et on discute avec mon coach on a plutôt
décidé d'accès
mon entraînement et mon travail sur le
400 mètres plutôt avant d'en savoir un
petit peu plus sur Babacar je voulais
tout d'abord vous demander pourquoi vous
avez choisi pour votre au premier coup
de coeur de nous présenter cette jeune
athlète alors c'est très simple déjà je
fais je fais de l'athlétisme donc
évidemment mon premier coup de cœur
allait aller pour un athlète Babacar je
me suis entraîné avec lui pendant trois
ans et j'ai vu son évolution et je me
suis dit statlet là il faut pas passer à
côté je voulais être la première à
Saint-Quentin à faire une chronique sur
lui à faire un sujet sur lui donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai choisi alors vous
parlez justement de son évolution on va
peut-être jeter un coup d'oeil sur son
palmarès parce qu'il a déjà un palmarès
très fourni un babarcada malgré son son
jeune âge il est champion de France en
salle du 200 mètres on va voir ça va
s'afficher dans quelques instants vice
champion de France du 200 mètres à
l'extérieur champion de France du relais
4 fois 100 mètres junior participation
toute récente à au championnat du monde
cadet sur 200 mètres et recordman de
France en salle du 400 mètres carrés il
déjà un bon CV comme on dit complètement
en très très bon CV sachant que que
Babacar a découvert l'athlé à 10 ans en
regardant les championnats du monde
d'athlétisme il s'est dit il a vu la
finale du 100 m et il s'est dit un jour
je vais être le roi du 100 m et il a mis
ses premières pointes ses premières
baskets et l'arrivée sur sur une piste
et après ça donne le bon résultat 8 ans
après ça donne le beau palmarès qu'on
vient de voir c'est déjà exceptionnel à
son âge vous aviez ce palmarès là ou pas
à son âge ou alors moi j'ai été loin de
ça j'étais loin de ça son âge parce que
je débutais tous un tout tout juste
l'athlétisme à 16 ans donc effectivement
deux ans après j'avais pas ce palmarès
là donc non non c'est vraiment un
athlète avec un gros gros potentiel
parce que aujourd'hui il a pas encore
exploré toutes ses qualités
il entre à peine dans le haut niveau et
dans dans l'entraînement du haut niveau
donc il a encore de très très belles
années devant lui je crois qu'il y a une
de ses qualités que vous avez repéré
assez facilement
tout à fait je vais demander d'abord
parce que moi j'avais repéré ça mais à
l'entraînement j'avais repéré ça mais je
lui ai demandé qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
ça ça force et il m'a tout de suite
répondu ma force et le mentale je me
suis dit bon allez tous les athlètes
disent que ma force c'est le mental ma
force et le mental et du coup je suis
parti demander la vie d'un de ses
coéquipiers d'entraînement et écouter ce
qu'il dit
la force de boire un cas pour moi c'est
le mental ce que dans l'essence on le
voit quand on a à bout qu'on craque et
bah lui il est toujours là il craque pas
il reste il reste solide dans sa tête et
pour moi c'est une des plus grandes
forces qu'il a il y a 2 ans et la colle
à feu championnat de France à Lens il
avait une petite blessure il était pas
bien il avait fait pour lui un mauvais
résultat je lui avais dit que de toutes
les manières que à mon avis dans deux
ans il allait exploser il allait faire
un beau truc et sur ça je me suis pas
trompé sauf que c'est vrai que l'année
dernière je pensais pas qu'il allait
progresser comme ça et j'étais
agréablement surpris si j'avais un
conseil à lui donner c'est qui continue
comme il est qui reste naturel à
s'entraîner
et puis les choses à mon avis vont venir
d'elle-même
vous parliez de l'aspect mental mais
chez tous les athlètes comme vous le
disiez c'est prédominant pourquoi chez
lui c'est encore plus prédominant alors
disons qu'à son âge à son âge avoir
cette telle maturité là dans
l'entraînement et dans le l'objectif en
fait qu'il veut atteindre c'est très
très rare aujourd'hui Babacar
s'entraîne 4 à 5 fois par semaine voire
plus en fonction des des périodes et
toujours motivé les séances sont très
dures quand on fait du 400 mètres on
prépare les 400 mètres les séances sont
très très dures la charge d'entraînement
est assez élevée et Babacar ne rechigne
jamais jamais jamais au travail c'est
tant que il faut courir ma Bacar court
voilà il est toujours le premier arrivé
et s'il faut partir le dernier il
partira le dernier très très sérieux
dans sa dans sa démarche il est très
rigoureux aussi moi je l'ai vu à
l'entraînement il y a pas un mot plus
haut que l'autre il est concentré sur
son objectif et très à l'écoute de son
entraîneur mais il sait pourquoi il est
là il est à toute confiance à son
entraîneur il sait pourquoi il est là il
sait ce qu'il faut faire pour arriver au
niveau qui veut atteindre donc il donne
les moyens je crois que vous lui avez
aussi demandé parce que quand on voit
son palmarès déjà à cet âge-là vous lui
avez demandé un petit peu ses objectifs
pour l'avenir parce qu'on peut
évidemment ne pas passer à côté des
ambitions quand on a déjà pas le marais
non non c'est sûr alors là aujourd'hui
il a quasiment tout gagné au niveau
national maintenant il faut qu'il montre
sa sa supériorité au niveau
internationale donc là il souhaite il
souhaite préparer les championnats du
monde de cet été et ne pas y aller que
pour y figurer je crois qu'on va
l'écouter d'ailleurs sur ces objectifs
futurs
de France je sais pas sur 200 ou 400
après cet été on verra bien mais j'ai
une championnat du monde de Junior dans
la tête
je vais pas trop m'avancer mais j'y
pense quand même
malgré tous ces titres déjà chez les
jeunes on sent qu'il a la tête sur les
épaules oui mais la tête sur les épaules
il sait ce qu'il veut comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure là il prépare
d'ailleurs son bac scientifique son bac
scientifique et souhaite tout comme son
idole Stéphane Diagana allier sa
préparation sa carrière de sportif de
haut niveau et ses études voilà donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas quelque chose
de simple à faire à cet âge là mais
Babacar je suis sûr qu'il y arrivera
des pistes d'athlétisme voulu voyez un
avenir radieux
ah non non moi je suis sûr que qu'on
entendra encore parler de Babacar je
suis sûr qu'on n'a pas fini d'en
entendre parler et pour tout vous dire
je discute avec certains autres
entraîneurs d'autres clubs et tout le
monde a remarqué Babacar tout le monde
me dit Babacar c'est un talent à l'état
pur donc voilà c'est c'est je suis plus
la seule à le dire l'entraîneur n'est
plus le salaire à dire même d'autres
entraîneurs l'ont remarqué donc voilà
une petite statistique peut-être pour
terminer moi j'ai remarqué que Babacar
au même âge court le 100m en 10 secondes
82 soit un dixième de mieux qu'un
certain Christophe Lemaitre c'est dire
si votre coup de cœur se justifie quand
on voit ces chiffres alors oui non c'est
sûr après il faut pas s'attarder
là-dessus
on ne connaît pas la progression de
chaque athlète Babacar sera très fort
après ce qui sera plus fort ou moins
fort ou est-ce qu'il fera les mêmes
résultats que Christophe les maîtres
seul l'avenir nous le dira mais en tout
cas comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
il est encore de belles avenir de belles
de belles années devant lui merci
beaucoup non c'est bien pour cette
première chronique et puis du coup on
vous retrouve le mois prochain pour un
nouveau coup de coeur merci Antonin une
quarantaine d'équipage était réunie ce
week-end dans la forêt de saint-apolline
du côté de plaisir pour des
démonstrations de course de chiens de
traîneaux portrait de deux pilotes
lemotions qui vont une passion plutôt
inédite à leurs équipages claire Cambier
pour les images
chez les noblets les hommes sont
mocheurs de père en fils Michael a guidé
un traîneau pour la première fois à
l'âge de 12 ans dans le sillage de son
père il transmet désormais sa passion à
son garçon Éric mais c'est seulement la
première année qu'il participe aux
courses de chiens de traîneaux 15 ans
après ses premières glisses il leur
laisse volontiers toute la gloire de la
performance c'est plus cher en fait que
sur les autres non on est là pour les
aider pour les aiguiller faire le
parcours en fait on les aide nous
simplement mais c'est eux qui font le
travail c'est pas c'est pas le nous ce
qu'on appelle c'est plus les chiens que
le chien ça on est fier de nos chiens
voilà c'est plus nos chiens qu'on va
mettre en avant que nous ça c'est une
règle que nous on a leur visage
angélique et mystérieux l'ont toujours
fait rêver passionnés de loups Jocelyne
acquiert un malamut un cousin du Husky
très vite la meute s'agrandit et les
courses de chiens de traîneaux
deviennent une évidence si Joe et ses
chiens s'entraînent désormais deux fois
par semaine
c'est pour ça que ce genre de petit
entraînement c'est très bien ça nous
permet de voir où en est où en est le
chien et nous c'est un test avant de
partir cet hiver deux de ses compagnons
du jour Pearl 6 ans et Crao 4 ans semble
pressés dans des coudre dans la forêt
mais de l'entente entre un musher et ses
chiens dépend la performance du traîneau
avec le chien c'est une passion c'est
sinon entre nous quoi on se parle même
pas parfois il nous comprennent quoi
Jocelyne réussira une belle performance
avec une vitesse moyenne de 16 km/h une
quarantaine d'équipage était présent
dans la forêt de saint-apolline ce
weekend
alors finalement on va avoir la première
réaction du nouveau champion de France
Walter de boxe je le disais en début
d'émission un mail el Moussaoui qui a
conquis ce week-end cette première
ceinture de champion de France catégorie
Walter un mec de bonsoir
bah je crois que le premier mot il y en
a qu'un seul c'est félicitations pour ce
premier titre
vous êtes plutôt satisfait de votre
combat de à Cergy ce samedi
je suis assez satisfait parce que
une c'est mon premier Giroud et de deux
Xbox un mec qui a énormément
d'expérience qui a 30 combats depuis que
moi elle disait dix années
au premier round dans ce qu'on a à vous
envoyer justement Franck à rocheforta au
tapis et derrière le combat c'est un peu
plus rééquilibré non
on va dire que la première partie de
combat je commence j'ai domination et
puis il revient de il revient dans la
deuxième partie et après on fait un
dernier round où là on bataille vraiment
voilà mais sinon c'était vraiment un
combat très disputé et voilà très
équilibré surtout il n'y a pas eu de
trop de bobos comme on dit un petit peu
après ce combat vous êtes pas trop
abîmés non il m'a pas fait mal j'ai pas
eu de bobos mais quelques petites
égratignures mais ça va rien de plus et
un peu de courbatures mais sinon ça va
ce titre ce premier titre sa récompense
un petit peu votre gestion de carrière
pour l'instant on voit que vous y allez
étape par étape c'est quoi la prochaine
étape derrière ce type de champion de
France je vous entends mal pardon quelle
est la prochaine étape après votre
premier titre là de champion de France
une défense de titre
peut-être en mars mais avant ça je pense
que je ferai un petit combat quand je
retournerai aux États-Unis un petit
combat histoire de me remettre ensemble
il y a encore cet objectif fin 2014
d'être dans le top 50 mondial
ouais bien sûr et puis pourquoi pas une
chance européenne d'ici là cette année
très bien merci beaucoup Ahmed d'avoir
accordé votre première réaction au sport
et à très bientôt sur sur le ring je
vous remercie à très bientôt à mettre au
revoir
allez après cette première réaction donc
du nouveau champion de France de boxe
professionnelle catégorie Walter qui est
de la verrière Moussaoui on passe au
résultat du weekend
tout d'abord football une fois n'est pas
coutume lors de la dixième journée de
Division d'Honneur Versailles a enchaîné
avec une troisième victoire consécutive
on s'imposant sur sa pelouse face à
Melun 2-1 de Busin les joueurs de David
Giguet remontent à la sixième place en
promotion d'honneur pour le compte de la
8e journée Guyancourt s'est incliné à
domicile face à Lognes sur le même score
de 1 les joueurs de jute talmorrose
restent bloqués à la huitième place et
non toujours pas réussi à enchaîner deux
victoires consécutives cette saison dans
la poule betterave continue de
s'accrocher à sa deuxième place en
s'imposant sur sa pelouse de 1 face à
Torcy c'était le score du week-end en
football féminin division 2 le chemin de
croix continue pour la jeunesse
inimmontaine lors de la dixième journée
Montigny c'est lourdement incliné à
temple marrant de ville sibuzza 2 les
joueuses de Jean Dany Grosset plus
mauvaise défense de leur groupe reste
lanterne rouge
place au rugby après leur défaite de
deux petits points chez le leader
Orléans il y a quelques jours les
joueurs du plaisir Rugby club avait
l'occasion de relever la tête ce
week-end avec la réception du septième
Saint Maur et les joueurs de Philippe
Béart ne se sont pas tombés dans le
piège comme l'année passée auteur d'une
excellente première période les plaisirs
en bleu et jaune inscrivent trois essais
sans en considérer un seul c'est un
morceau sauvera l'honneur sur pénalité
le PRC s'imposef facilement pardon 17 à
3 et deuxième execo avec
Pontault-Combault avec 33 points je vous
propose d'ailleurs d'écouter le
capitaine plaisir roi François le vilain
au micro de Claire Cambier après la
rencontre
on fait une très bonne première mi-temps
je pense que on avait à cœur de de faire
un bon match un pour le classement et
deux parce que l'année dernière ils
viennent gagner à la maison et du coup
bon bah on avait un petit peu à cœur de
se rattraper de ce mauvais match et donc
du coup c'est chose faite et donc c'est
bonne augure pour la suite de la saison
la fin de la saison on a encore un match
important à jouer la semaine prochaine à
soucis si on peut faire une victoire
avant tout à l'extérieur et puis aller
peut-être gagner ces 5 points ça sera ça
sera une très belle fin de saison et
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut pour pour
assurer l'objectif qui est au moins
essayer de finir deuxième année quoi
c'est la fin de ce site sport avec des
résultats un petit peu coupés tous les
résultats dans le prochain 7 8
actuellement avec wilfriedrichy d'ici là
excellente soirée sur TV